you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
as global temperatures tick up but
scientists warn a key
limit could be reached in the next five
years
the gulf state reliant on oil but at
risk from climate change
we speak to bahrain's climate envoy
and plea to leave nothing but footprints
behind
if you're visiting the uk's beaches this
half turn
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
coming up the species of giant tortoise
rediscovered on the galapagos islands
after 100 years
but first let's go straight over to our
data dashboard and take a look at
this number here now this is an estimate
of how much
humans have warmed our planet since the
industrial revolution and you can see
it's ticking up every single second
now the aim agreed by 196 parties in the
paris accord of 2015
is to keep that number below 2 degrees
preferably
to 1.5 degrees of warming because above
that
we could see more extreme weather higher
sea levels
more people forced from their homes and
more climate-related disasters
but scientists are warning today there's
a 40 chance that will temporarily
hit 1.5 degrees in at least one of the
next
five years and these odds are increasing
all the time
according to the world meteorological
organization
well with me now is max dilly who's
climate program director at the world
meteorological
organization hello to you how much of a
concern is it if the temperature does go
up to that 1.5 degree
level temporarily if it then drops back
down again
yeah uh it's a good question because the
paris agreement obviously has a
long-term
focus and the the temperature goal in
the paris agreement is a long-term
global goal so if the temperature goes
above 1.5 degrees
as a global average temporarily it
doesn't mean that the paris agreement
has failed
uh intention is to try to keep that
long-term
uh temperature average within those
limits so
hopefully less than 1.5 degrees but
certainly less than two
the issue is and the the warning that
we're getting now
is that uh currently the global
temperature in 2020 was already 1.2
degrees above pre-industrial levels so
that's
close to 1.5 and now as you said in the
introduction
our forecasts are that there's a growing
chance that it could start to come up
above 1.5
um in the next five years well yes and
what are you learning about those longer
term averages to what extent
is the trend an upward one
well the trend is clearly an upward one
and we see that just
from the observational record
the warmest year on record was 2016.
that was about 1.3 degrees above
pre-industrial levels but there was a
strong el nino event at the time and
that tends to
give the temperature a little bit of a
boost but the last
five years have been the warmest five
years on record the last decade was the
warmest
decade on record and the decades
successively before
the last the current decade have all
been uh the warmest decades on record
to that point so we see a clear upward
trend and unless
uh something is done to control the
emissions that that trend will certainly
continue
and how do you do your calculations
well um the the the product uh that
has the uh current information that
we're discussing
now in it is a new product it was
developed
under the leadership of the the the met
office
um acting as a lead center for um
annual to decadal forecasting meaning
that the
the lead center pulls together forecast
information from the other
global producing centers of these
long-range forecasts
so to qualify as a forecast or a
prediction
there has to be a skill assessment it's
not a projection which is just
running the science forward and seeing
what the computer models suggest would
happen
it's actually something that's verified
by running it against historical data
and seeing what the skill is
the skill for global average temperature
is
a very highly skillful prediction so
because it's a it's a single number it's
not nearly as complicated to predict as
something like local rainfall which is
um something that's a lot more
challenging max delhi thanks very much
indeed
it's a pleasure in today's other climate
news the government's being urged to put
plastic pollution on the agenda when it
hosts next month's g7 summit
more than 30 business leaders
environmentalists and mps
want ministers to discuss a global
treaty on plastics
they say 300 million tons of plastic
waste is produced every year
while less than 10 of all plastic ever
produced has been recycled
co2 emissions from private jets have
increased by nearly a third
rising faster than commercial planes a
new report by
transport and environment shows carbon
dioxide from private flights in europe
increased by 31 between 2005
and 2019. the campaign group says the uk
is responsible for nearly a fifth of
these emissions making it the worst
country in europe
for private jet pollution
a tortoise thought to have become
extinct a hundred years ago has been
found
alive on the galapagos islands
scientists use genetic testing to
confirm the female is part of a species
known as the fernandina
giant tortoise an expedition is now
being planned to try and find
other surviving members of the species
an australian court has ruled the
government has a duty to protect
young people from the climate crisis
eight teenagers brought the case to
court to stop the expansion of a coal
mine in new south wales
the judge stopped short of issuing an
injunction saying he was satisfied the
environment minister
wouldn't breach her duty of care one of
the teenagers involved
anjali sharma said she sees today's
result as a win
the court has accepted the biggest part
of our
argument which was that the environment
owes us a duty of care
and now while the court today didn't
decide to grant an injunction
we have been granted an order um both
parties to come together and work out
um a way forward out of this so while it
might might seem like we've won the
battle but not the war the war is still
um still going on and the last part of
this battle is still up for grabs
and you can hear more from anjali in
this week's episode of climate cast is
out tomorrow
wherever you normally get your podcast
from
climate change impacts every single
country in the world but often we focus
on the role of the big emitters such as
china and the united states
but smaller nations such as bahrain have
a role to play too
and in a moment i'll be speaking to the
country's special envoy for climate
affairs
but first let's take a closer look at
the gulf state
well bahrain's position as a small
island means it's impacted by climate
change
in a variety of ways firstly rising sea
levels the highest point is 134 metres
above sea level
with most of the coast no higher than 5
meters and a mild
estimate on sea level rise due to
climate change predicts
more than a quarter of the country could
be underwater by the end of the century
now an increase in global temperature
will also exacerbate
the scarcity of usable water placing
bahrain
in the top seven countries water
stressed by 2040.
the country's economy relies on vast
sums generated from
oil refineries but the government has
applied for almost 10 million dollars of
assistance from the un's
green climate fund the country's carbon
dioxide emissions have been stable for
the last few years at around
22 tonnes of carbon dioxide per capita
now that puts it
in the top 10 of all countries in the
world in terms of co2
emissions per person well joining me now
is dr mohammed bin
dana special envoy of climate change for
the government of bahrain hello to you
so as we heard that bahrain is at risk
of suffering some of the worst effects
of climate change so how concerned are
you and what are you doing to mitigate
against the effects
we're actually thinking as a small
island developing states on on the
adaptations with the climate change
we managed to look at the sea level rise
we developed
a simulator that measures the impact of
the sea level rise on our shores
and our own infrastructures we set up a
target
220 50 of 0.5 meter
and we build a brazilian's plan to adapt
with the climate change
up to this level we managed also to work
on developing a national adaptation
investments plan because the financing
for the adaptation
project is is very important and crucial
now international
climate activism activism has played a
huge role
in recent weeks putting pressures on
governments and corporations
to meet their commitments on climate
change bahrain has
repeatedly stifled protest and activism
so can you guarantee that climate
activists
will be given freedom to speak out
we and bahrain have a very democratic
institution and we have the house of
parliament
and under um the government
the freedom of speech is always
available for
everybody in bahrain not just um
the environmentalist
human rights groups would argue with
that of course they would say that their
freedom of speech is stifled
they could argue as as much as they want
but this is not actually the truth the
truth is
everybody as per the constitution has
the right to speak in bahrain
okay well we will leave it there dr
muhammad bin dana thanks very much
indeed
thank you thank you now with holidays
abroad off the cards for many this
summer british beaches are expected to
be busier than ever
and a new campaign is hoping to keep our
coastline clean by asking everyone who
visits a beach
to pick up five pieces of litter well
earlier i spoke to tv presenter and un
patron of the wilderness
ben fogle and asked him why keeping
beaches clean
is so important you can see i'm on a
beautiful
[Music]
do have plenty of beach beaches like
this you only need to turn the corner
and find where the prevailing winds are
the prevailing currents and it's a very
different picture
there's a misconception that it's
picnickers who go to the beach and just
leave their rubbish behind that's not
really the case
it's stuff that has emptied into the
ocean rivers all around the world
it's um it's stuff that's been lost or
thrown off the back of ships and vessels
and i think we all have a
responsibility to protect
well that's everything from us for today
on the daily climate show tomorrow
how abandoned fishing nets littering the
ocean
are being transformed into ppe in
thailand
that's at the same time tomorrow here on
sky news see you then